So as usual uh let's start from our
classic road map uh just to to have an
exact point of where where we are right
now. Uh so over the last uh week or so
we started approaching the this quadrant
of the road map. Specifically we started
looking at uh openloop uh methods for
optimal control. uh last uh Monday we
started looking at indirect methods for
optimal control and we'll spend also
today in this box over here and uh
Monday then next week Wednesday we'll
move to direct methods for uh open loop
optimal control and then we'll move
towards uh closed loop methods uh in the
following weeks
and uh I just want to make sure that we
have kind of the key takeaways in place
and specifically when on Monday we
introduced indirect methods we
essentially said that indirect methods
are a way of defining necessary
optimality conditions for optimal
control problems. uh in their infinite
dimensional optimization case and
specifically again what I mean by
infinite dimensional
is that
we want to optimize with uh over
functionals which are in and of itself
kind of loosely speaking defined as
functions over functions. So we want to
find the optimal control u star of t
that optimizes a given functional that
is given to us. And again u of t is a
continuous signal in the sense that it
is defined between some time t0 and tf.
And again loosely speaking it represents
to optimizing the full uh kind of
control signal over time. And in order
to derive these necessary optimality
conditions, we had to extend basically
everything we know from the kind of
domain of finite dimensional
optimization
um and essentially derived kind of a key
result which is the fundamental theorem
of calculus of variation. So these
slides are not the ones you will find on
online. These are just some selected
slides from from Monday just to to to
recap. Um so the and the key result is
this fundamental theorem of calculus
operations which essentially says that
for a function XAR to be an extreal. So
loosely speaking kind of a local minimum
for or optimum for for our functional uh
the variation of J must b must vanish at
uh x of star. Namely we derive this uh
equation here that the variation of of j
of our cost function j evaluated up the
optimal x of star needs to be zero for
all admissible variations uh delta x.
And kind of in your mental map,
something that I want to stress is that
this condition here uh when we map it
to the finite dimensional case
should essentially feel as if we are
saying that the differential is equal to
zero. So that the gradient of f
transpose delta x is equal to zero.
Now this result is obviously important
because it characterizes what is a local
minimum in our case in the case of
infinite dimensional functions but it is
not actionable. So what we did on Monday
is that we took a specific simplified
optimal control problem which is
essentially the one where we were
assuming to have a functional defined
through this stage wise cost G which is
a function of x of t uh x dot of t and
time. And so essentially speaking here
we refer to it as simplified because if
it is if it's as is we are directly
controlling the state trajectory. So no
explicit controls u in this case and we
were assuming um and we essentially
derived kind of from the fundamental
theorem of calculus operation an
actionable strategy to solve these
problems and to define necessary and
optimality conditions.
And of course we did this in the case
where both the initial and final
conditions were fixed. So the initial
time and final time were fixed and the
initial state x and final state x at tf
is also fixed.
And so we started if you remember kind
of a derivation where we took the
increment of the functional we
linearized. So we took the linear part
of that increment and then we derived a
condition on that linear part of the
increment which boiled down to the euler
equation. essentially here is where we
kind of fasttracked uh Newton in uh in
just one lecture essentially and if and
here is where I want to now delve a
little bit deeper because we didn't have
time on Monday is that this Uler
equation is again in your mental model
you should essentially see the
Euler equation as the analog of the
gradient of f equal to zero condition in
the finite dimensional case because now
this is actionable right we can actually
compute
Now let's look a little bit closer at
what this uler equation looks like. It
is a nonlinear uh ordinary differential
equation specifically a second order uh
differential equation because here we
have a function g of x dot uh that is
also is differentiated uh with respect
to time once more here and specifically
it is an equation with split boundary
conditions.
So now you might be more familiar with
uh kind of the type of uh differential
equations which uh are regarded as kind
of in the form of Koshi problems where
usually the boundary the uh boundary
conditions are only one-sided for
example at the initial time zero but
here is if if you wish this is a
slightly nastier object because in this
case the boundary conditions are split.
So we have them both at the beginning
and at at the end of of of of time in
this case.
Okay.
Uh any any questions on on this point?
>> Yes.
>> Instead of like uh an optimal like
control sequence.
>> Yeah. So this is derived on this kind of
simplified setting where we are assuming
that we can control the kind of the
dynamics if you wish as if we're
directly controlling the the state
trajectory. Uh in in the next slides we
will kind of relax some of these
assumptions and build towards an actual
optimal control problem.
Okay. Okay. So what we'll do now is I'll
spend maybe 5 minutes or so doing a
concrete example of how to use these uh
optimality conditions in practice and
then we'll move towards relaxing these
uh boundary conditions and these
simplifying assumptions that we just
introduced here.
Okay. And specifically the problem we'll
be looking at is the one of finding
the
minimum shortest path between two
points.
So even just to build kind of a mental
map assume we are at a specific time
time zero and x of sub0.
We want to find the shortest line that
connects these two these two points and
it will give us kind of great
satisfaction in deriving the fact that
this is actually the straight line. Um
and the way we will do this of course is
by leveraging calculus of variation.
So remember that uh first of all to
approach this problem we have to define
what is a functional that represents
kind of the minimum distance between
these two points. And remember from
kind of your calculus classes that in
order to measure the length of of a
line, what we do in practice is that we
take a kind of infinite decimal segment
uh ds and then we integrate it over the
entire length of the line. And so for us
kind of we will define the so kind of
the length of the segment is something
along the lines of taking this
infinitizing all displacement and just
integrating it over the the length of
the line. Now how do we calculate this
in practice? As usual we are often only
good at uh handling linear objects. And
so assuming that kind of uh ds is is is
small enough we do this by taking an
infinite decimal displacement in in time
which I'm calling dt
and in the x direction which I'm calling
dx. And so from the
using a pilagorian theorem we can
approximate ds as
d s 2 equ= dt ^ 2 + d delta x^ 2.
Okay.
From this we can of course derive the
fact that delta s is equal to the square
root of dt ^ 2 plus delta x^2.
Taking delta t out of the square root
you get that delta t multiplies the
square root of 1 +
delta x over delta t squared.
And assuming there are no mathematicians
in this in this class here, we are kind
of redefining this as x dot.
And so this leads to kind of our
definition of the functional j as the
integral between t0 and tf of our
equation that we just derived for uh ts
which is essentially the square root of
1 + x dot of t squared
in the t.
And this is essentially our g of x x dot
t.
Yeah. Okay.
So now to solve this we want to be uh
methodical. So we want to apply uh uler
equations. So our necessary and
optimality conditions.
So to do this what we need is to first
of all compute uh g of x and g of x dot
which as a reminder
so g of x is equal to the derivative of
g with respect to x which in this case
the g does not depend on x it only
depends on x dot and so this is equal to
to zero.
The next thing that we need is indeed to
define g of x dot
which is 1
over
*<unk> 1 + x dot
squared
time 2 * uh x dot.
The two cancels cancel out. And so for
us, g of x dot is essentially x dot * 1
+ x dot^ 2 power of the -1 /2.
Okay. So here we're just basically uh
computing those those terms that we need
for in order to apply the the uler
equation.
Okay. So now what we want is indeed just
computing that and spelling out that
uler equation. So what we need is to
compute the derivative. So we know that
the first term is is zero. And so what
we need is the derivative of g of x dot
with respect to time which is equal to x
dot * 1 + x dot^ 2 to the powers of -1
/2
plus the derivative of the second term
which is indeed x dot
multiplied - 12 * 1 + x dot^ 2 to the^
of -3 /2
multiplied by the derivative of the term
inside which is 2 x dot x dot.
Again it's just some uh derivations
here.
Now we can rewrite this as x dot
over 1 + x dot^ 2 to the power of 12
minus
x dot 2 * x dot
over 1 + x dot^ 2
to the^ 3 / 2
which we can rewrite as X dot + X dot *
X dot 2
- X dot 2 X dot all everything over 1 +
X dot squared to the power of 3 / R2
which finally is equal to X dot / 1 + X
dot^ 2 to the power of 3 /2
Okay. So now basically what we have is
we have all of the both of the terms
that we need for our uler equation
and essentially we can then write our
necessary optimality conditions as the
fact that so g of x is equal to zero.
And so we can write that x uh double dot
has to be over 1 + x uh dot squared
to power 3 / 2 needs to be equal to
zero.
Now we know that this is always positive
and so the only way for uh this term to
be equal to zero is that x dot has to be
equal to zero.
And so we essentially reach that this is
now the our uh uler equation kind of
fully fleshed out. Um which needs of
course our uh boundary conditions which
in our case are that x of t0
is equal to x0 and x of tf are equal to
uh xf. Again here we didn't really
specify what x0 and xs are. Uh but this
is where uh what the boundary conditions
look like.
Now this is something we we know how to
solve. So uh
what what is the the solution here
when we integrate uh x a double dot z?
Yes.
>> It's a straight line.
>> Yeah. Exactly. So kind of writing it
down it means that x of t is equal to c1
t plus uh c2
which it is indeed the uh basically the
formula of a line right the equation of
a line.
Now notice that here we have uh again
kind of pointing your attention to the
fact that this is a second order
differential equation. This will need uh
kind of two constants of integration
that we need to pinpoint. And so here
we're using our two boundary conditions
to pinpoint those constants of
integration.
And so we indeed prove that the shortest
uh path between two points is is a line.
Now formally what we proved here is that
the line is a candidate for optimality.
Uh there are kind of second order
arguments you could could be done here
to actually prove that this is a an
actual optimal. But this is the the kind
of way mechanically in which we would
use these uh these conditions.
Okay.
All right. Now if this is clear um I
would move towards what is probably the
most interesting for us for the purpose
of this class which is um wanting to now
apply these ideas towards the anoptimal
control problem. And to do this, we need
to extend kind of and relax some of
these assumptions we're doing to
simplify the setup.
>> Yes.
>> X do.
Oh, is that an X double dot?
>> Uh where? Sorry.
>> Oh, it's a double dot.
>> This is double dot. Yes.
>> Yes. Ellie made sure that the markers
are all uh nice and working today. So,
>> you just integrated, right? So once you
have that x dot that's zero literally
just
>> okay.
>> All right.
Okay. So this is the mechanics of how
you would use uh kind of the uler
equation essentially the optimality
conditions for the case we're looking
at. And now we want to build towards
problems that we actually care about
solving which are optimal control
problems. And so the first kind of uh
extension that we want to do to this
formalism is uh relaxing the assumptions
that the boundary conditions are fixed.
So we derived all of this using the fact
that initial time final time initial
state kind of condition and final
condition were fixed. And so we want to
relax this assumption. And so what we do
here is we take the exact same setup. Uh
now formally we're considering functions
which map reals to real in Rn. Uh so
we're just like a multi-dimensional
version of that but it does it shouldn't
bother you. It's exactly the same the
same thing. Um with the usual
assumptions we're assuming that g is
twice differentiable. The initial
conditions t0 and x sub0 are fixed. But
now we are relaxing the fact that the
final time might and and x of tf might
be fixed or free.
And so
essentially uh what hap what we want to
do here is kind of adjust the kind of
our optimality conditions in order to
handle these uh these cases. Now the the
problem here as you can probably imagine
is that so we we showed here already on
this example that the optimality
conditions boils down to solving these
uh differential equations. In order to
solve them we need to pinpoint uh kind
of some constants of integrations. And
here we use the fact that we had these
uh boundary conditions fixed to pinpoint
those constants of integrations. But the
moment we are relaxing this we are
missing some boundary conditions. So
essentially what happens here is is that
the uler equation remains uh valid. So
it still has to hold but now we're
lacking these boundary conditions to
pinpoint the constants of integration.
And so this is uh uh kind of in general
for today uh I will be limiting myself
to uh stating the results. We'll be
proving also some of them but most of
the proofs are one very similar to the
kind of uh manipulations we did on
Monday and so not very insightful in and
of itself. And so I will focus on
stating the results and showing you how
to how to use them.
And so the fact here is that we need to
have a more sophisticated version of the
boundary conditions.
And specifically the boundary conditions
are found from this equation here which
you know at the first approach might
seem like a very nasty equation to deal
with. So let me uh unpack it and show
you how how to use it. So first of all
notice that here we have these two uh
terms which are uh which comprehend kind
of these delta xf
and delta tf. So we have the variations
in the uh in xf and and the final time.
The trick here will be that uh we will
have to make the appropriate quote
unquote substitutions for these delta x
terms. And so very kind of very
practically if we are in a setting where
delta x again delta x here represents
the admissible variations that we can
allow at the final state xf uh so if
delta x is fixed it means that we the
only admissible variation here is zero
and so this entire term will go to zero
and so we're only left with this other
part of the of the boundary condition.
Same thing for delta TF. So we'll be
using the fact that either one or the
other might are fixed or free in order
to basically uh compute the boundary the
additional boundary conditions from this
equation over here.
And you can imagine there are a number
of different cases. uh we won't go
through all of them but there are like
there are some nice tables which
basically summarize all of the uh cases
that we can find and different
combinations. So for example if we look
at the very first one this is the
setting we were on Monday and in the
example that we just showed where both
XTF and TF were specified and so this
essentially entails that the boundary
conditions are the uh you know initial
state initial and final state in and of
itself. Uh on the other hand if the
final uh x of tf is free and the final
time is specified
what we get is essentially
uh this that the derivative of g with
respect to x dot evaluated at the final
time needs to be equal to zero
which is indeed only this part here.
Right? So if TF is u fixed delta TF is
zero and so all of this gets canceled
out and so what remains is this part
over here and so we know that if this is
free so we can have all any possible any
admissible variation in order for all of
this to be equal to zero then this part
has to be equal to zero.
Okay, so nothing too crazy here, but at
the very high level, what we're doing is
that we are extending the current
formalism. When we extend it to
generalized boundary conditions, we're
lacking some uh uh some boundary
conditions to pinpoint concepts of
integrations. And we can derive them
through this equation over here, which
ends up being kind of a case- by case
analysis on essentially pinpointing
those those boundary those constants of
integration.
Does this make sense?
Okay, great.
So now again to kind of uh see this in
practice how this works, let's take a
very related problem in a way.
You're talking about your boundary
condition.
Is that always assuming that to be said?
>> Uh me.
>> Uh I noticed that the initial time for
the x is not in there. It's only whether
or not x and tf are set. Um is that
because we're and it also didn't show up
in the equation, but it's always set.
It's being essential. So it's always a
system that's always been fixed.
>> Yeah. I mean usually you if you think
about it from an optimal control problem
you know where you are now and you know
what time is
>> okay but like there could be also some
problems where it's like um when are you
going to start necessarily measuring or
something like that perspective or like
it can start at any time if you're
thinking maybe not from an a point of
view but maybe from a optimizing some
type of point and when you're going to
make this decision or something
um but then it wouldn't we wouldn't be
able to use this method
>> I think you can always reformulate your
problem such that you're starting from
zero time 0 and say zero. You can always
re reshift and rear your problem to to
always have the initial conditions are
given. Does that make sense?
>> Yeah.
Okay. And so the
example we'll be looking at specifically
is one where we want to determine again
the the smooth curve or smaller length
that connects
point x uh of 0 = 1 to
kind of a free final point x of tf but
on the line t = 5. So here we're
assuming we have a fixed final time of
t= 5. We have a fixed initial condition
x of0als 1. But then we want to find the
curve of smooth kind of shortest length
that connects to this line here. So we
want to find the the final x of tf. So
in you know it could be this line over
here. It could be this line over here
could be this other function over here.
But most likely it'll be this one here.
Right? And so uh let us now approach it
from the perspective of the optimality
conditions which we just introduced.
So again as we were doing uh here above
the uh cost functional will be the same.
So we keep this cost functional over
here
and we already applied the uler. So we
know
from the treatment we were doing here
that the uler condition still holds
right. So we can leverage the results
that we had here above. meaning that the
uler condition uh essentially boils down
to uh this equation over here right
which just for practicality let me
rewrite. So we derived above that x of t
is equal to c1 t + uh c2. Now in this
case we have one boundary condition
which is that x of0 is equal to 1. And
so from uh these two we can evaluate x
at time z which is equal to c1 * 0 plus
um c2 and this must be equal to one
right
which essentially means that
uh c2 is equal to one right
so we use the initial uh condition to
pinpoint one of the two constants of
integration.
Now, how do we find the other one? So,
C1, we are missing, as we were saying
before, one of these boundary
conditions. And so, we'll use the the
one we just derived on the slide. And
again, we want to be methodical. So, the
way we do this is that from the table
we are in the case where TF is specified
uh but X of TF is free. So we already
used this boundary condition over here.
Now we want to use the second one.
Okay, which in practice boils down to
evaluating the relative g with respect
to x dot
which we did again before but let me
just rewrite it here which is 1 / 2 *
square<unk> of x uh 1 + x 2
x dot
* 2x
dot.
And so what we want in practice is that
we uh want to take this expression. So
looking at the boundary condition, we
take this expression, we evaluate it at
time tf and we set it equal to zero.
So this leads to
x dot of tf
over square<unk> of 1 + x dot of tf
uh equal to zero
which essentially means that
x dot of tf is equal to zero
Right.
So now we know from
here we know that uh x of t is equal to
uh c1 t + 1 because c2 is equal to 1.
uh which essentially means that
x dot of t from from here
is equal to uh c1
right by differentiating this.
And so basically now what we have is
that by combining these two we can
essentially derive that c1 is equal to
zero because we are evaluating this at
the final time and we know that this is
equal to zero. So c1 must be equal to
zero.
Right.
So now what we get kind of as a final
result is that we pinpointed both of our
constants of integration. And so we have
that C1 is equal to 0. C2 is equal to 1.
And so we get that X of T is equal 1
which is indeed this line right here.
Again, nothing too deep here. Uh it's
exactly the same mechanics. Uh I just
showed you an example of how do we
derive those additional boundary
conditions in the moment we don't have
the uh necessary boundary conditions
that are needed.
Okay.
Okay. So in general just as a caveat um
the moment we have uh kind of
multi-dimensional
uh functions that we're dealing with uh
the exact same mechanics apply we just
apply them uh component wise. So again
nothing really deep here. We used
everything assuming we had functions
that maps mapped reals to reals. But in
the moment where we have
multi-dimensional uh functions, we would
apply all of the boundary conditions and
all the uler equations uh per component.
Okay. The second extension that I want
to briefly uh touch upon I I say briefly
because we will be expanding on it in
the context of optimal control uh in a
few slides from now is the one where we
are considering constraints that link
together uh the function wt in this case
with the derivative of the the
derivative of the function wt with the
function itself. Yes.
>> Just on that example,
I might not be seeing something, but I'm
wondering how you got x= 1 and not x=
>> we because we pinpointed this constant
of integration. Uh
this one here where is it? Yeah, c2
equals 1.
>> Okay.
>> Right. So we know that x of t is c1 t +
c2. And we pinpointed both c2 is 1 and
c1 is zero. And so you get that x of t
is equal one.
Okay.
So again what we're doing here is we
want to uh bring forward a second
extension that we're doing to the
current formalism. Specifically we're
interested in having uh extensions to
the fact where we have constraints that
tie together the derivative of a
function with the function itself. And
so here we're considering a situation
where say we have a function w that maps
reals into r n + m um where we want to
essentially find the extrema for w star
that basically optimizes this functional
over here uh which is the exact same uh
situation we were uh seeing before but
now we have everything expressed in this
uh in this W. Now notice that uh the
constraints here are only with respect
to the first n dimensions. So w is a
function that maps in n plus m. We have
n constraints. And so kind of if you
wish kind of a way you can interpret it
as taking a step into the direction of
what we care about is that n could be
our state dimensions, m could be our
controls. And so we have a a constraint
here which represents the analog of the
system dynamics which essentially ties
together the controls the which are the
m free variables with the n uh states
>> just clarification when so in this
situation where we were previously doing
assuming x is like a number now you're
calling it w making it a vector and then
you're also I
Yes, exactly.
>> So if you wish the extension of calling
it W and being it a vector value
function is just extending from
functions that map real to real into
vector value functions. The only thing
that we're adding here is this type of
constraints. Yeah.
Okay. And and so indeed we we mentioned
that only M of the N plus N components
of W are independent. uh and constraints
of this type might may represent the
state equations such as the system
dynamics. And so indeed maybe one way to
interpret it is just w is the
concatenation of our states and controls
uh variables control functions.
And so uh the way we handle this uh is
similar to the way in which we handled
in finite dimensional optimization the
constrained setting. And specifically in
finite dimensional optimization if you
remember we introduced the concept of
lrangen where essentially we took the
constraint we added it to the objective
function uh together with some lrange
multipliers which we called lambda and
then we treated the problem as if it was
unconstrained. So essentially this term
represented like a penalty for violating
those constraints. And so here what we
do is exactly the same thing in the
sense that we uh posit an augmented uh
integrant function g specifically g of a
um which is the original g plus this uh
term here which represents the
constraint multiplied by this p of t
which is uh the analog of the lrangen
multipliers. Now notice that in the
finite dimensional optimization lambdas
was just a vector of values. Now p of t
is a function of time in and of itself.
Uh and is usually referred to as the
coate in literature. Cost coate because
you have one uh function for every state
uh that you have in your system.
Um yeah again so we're changing notation
because this is what you will find uh in
literature most most commonly. But this
is the exactly the analog of the lambda
uh variables that we introduced in
finite dimensions.
Okay, so the
point here is that we are extending our
necessary optimality conditions to
various extensions. And so what you get
is that uh the optimality conditions for
this case. So the case where we are
introducing this kind of constraints
essentially boils down to the enforcing
the Uler equation this time on the
augmented cost. So again, we're using
the exact same trick we did in finite
dimensions. So we took the constraint,
we added it to the objective function,
and we're treating it as if it was
unconstrained. And so this is exactly
the same thing that we're doing here.
We're taking our differential
constraints, adding them to the original
cost function G, defining the augmented
cost G of A and uh applying the uler
equation to this G of A.
Of course, here there is an additional
condition that is the fact that the
constraints must be satisfied, right?
So, if a function is optimal, it has to
be also satisfying those constraints.
And indeed, notice again the similarity
with the respect to the finite
dimensional uh optimization.
Again, this I just wanted to kind of
share the intuition of how we deal with
this. We'll formalize it in in a couple
of slides.
Okay. And so given these two extensions,
we were treating them from the broader
perspective of calculus of variation,
which is this tool kind of mathematical
tool we're using to solve uh problems
over functions. But now we want to go
into things that we actually care about
which is solving optimal control
problems. And we will do this in kind of
three steps actually four. Today we'll
only look at the first one uh which is
we will be uh deriving uh necessary of
humanity conditions for optimal control
problems assuming that the uh controls
admissible controls are not bounded. So
we won't be assuming controls such as uh
constraints uh such as uh maximum
thrusts on the controls.
on uh Monday next week we'll be
introducing kind of the celebrated uh
pontraan minimum principle uh which is
essentially the generalization of these
optimality conditions to the case where
the controls uh may be bounded
and then we will apply these optimality
conditions to a number of known cases
showing that we can derive known uh
strategies for controls such as bang
bang controls to those of you that are
familiar with that and then the fourth
that is not listed here is that we will
be looking at uh computational methods
for solving these uh differential
equations. So until now we've solved
these problems analytically if you wish
uh in practice uh how you will use them
uh you know in this class and
potentially in your career is that you
will be using the optimality conditions
to derive these differential equations.
You derive the boundary conditions for
your specific case and then you feed
both so the differential equations and
the boundary conditions to a numerical
solver which will take care of the
solution for you. Uh and so this is why
indirect methods are also called
optimize then discretise because here
we're formulating the optimal solution.
So the optimize part and then the
discretization part usually comes when
you feed this into our numerical solver.
Is the plan does the plan make sense?
and any questions so far?
So um let us consider now the optimal
control problem with unbounded controls.
So specifically as we introduced also uh
a couple times in the previous lectures,
the problem here is we want to find an
admissible control u star which causes
the dynamical system represented by this
uh differential equation to follow an
admissible trajectory x of that
minimizes the following cost functional.
The cost functional is composed of two
terms. Uh stage uh cost represented by g
uh which is a function of x and u and
time. Usually uh g is something that is
you know accumulated over time and could
represent things like uh control effort.
So maybe something like u ^ squ. Uh so
you don't want to maybe push too much on
the on the throttle or something like
that. and a terminal cost which depends
only on the uh final time. Uh so the
state at the final time and this could
represent something like making sure
that you're actually hitting the target
that you want to hit.
Uh notice that uh J so the cost is only
a function of U because this U are our
free variables our controls and the
state that corresponds to our control
signal are kind of implicitly defined
through the system dynamics.
So this is the setup we introduced
before uh but just making sure that this
is exactly where we are we're going into
and we're assuming that uh the initial
time and initial conditions are are
fixed.
Okay. So the way I will uh go by
deriving the optimality conditions is in
three steps. So first I'll state them.
Then we will go through an example
showing how to apply them and then we'll
go through a sketch of a proof of how we
uh can derive these results. So the
optimality conditions are
not nothing more than this slide nothing
less than this slide over here. So
specifically
um the optimality conditions state that
we define the Hamiltonian meaning we
augment the cost with the constraint. So
exactly how we did before through the
kind of equivalent of the lrangen our
co-state variables p of t
and then kind of define the optimality
conditions uh whereby an optimal x p u
triplet must satisfy uh some
differential equations. We'll have a
look at them more later. Uh given some
boundary conditions which are given
through this equation over here which we
can handle exactly how we did before
depending on uh if our final time or xf
are fixed or not.
So let's have a look a little bit more
closely at uh what these differential
equations look like. So the first one is
uh obvious because these are essentially
the uh dynamics constraints. So if you
look at the uh Hamiltonian here and take
the uh derivative with respect to the
co-state p of t what you're left with is
that uh you're left with the dynamics
you're left with f right so essentially
this this condition over here is just
saying that for a triplet to be optimal
it needs to satisfy the dynamics make
sense the second and third are less
intuitive we'll derive them in in a
But very mechanically what you typically
do is that you would u essentially
define the Hamiltonian. You then posit
these differential equations. You use
the third which are uh m algebraic
equations. Actually this is not a
differential equation to express u as a
function of p and x and then you
basically solve these differential
equations using the boundary conditions
to pinpoint the constants of
integration.
>> Yes.
>> Yes. So it's a it's a good question.
It's important this that this is clear.
So remember how um we were looking
before at the case where we introduced
the uh constraints represented by the
dynamics and in order to handle these we
used kind of a very similar logic that
from the one that we used in finite
dimensions which is when we have a
constraint in order to handle it we take
that constraint and we augment the cost
with a penalty for that constraint and
then we treat the problem as if it was
unconstrained. And so in finite
dimensions we did this through lranch
multipliers which are the lambdas if you
if you recall. And the co state here is
playing the exact same role but this
time in the context of continuous uh
time uh functions. Um and it represents
the analog of the lrange multipliers
which we call co-state and label them as
p.
Does it make sense?
Any
[snorts]
other question on on this? So again here
I'm just stating what the optimality
conditions are for the optimal control
problem we're interested in. And these
optimality conditions look as uh this
set of uh uh differential equations with
accompanying boundary conditions
and mechanically we will see how to use
them but it is uh mechanically it's kind
of a process where we uh compose the
Hamiltonian by essentially augmenting
the cost through our dynamics. We define
these differential equations and then we
solve for them by using the boundary
conditions.
Okay, as we were doing before of course
uh in order to uh find the
correct boundary conditions uh it's also
a case a case by case scenario and so we
have kind of equivalent uh tables as we
were having in the in the previous case.
Yeah,
>> I was just I also had a question about
the previous slide. How did you restate?
You were saying something you solve the
last for you and then do something like
that.
>> Yeah. So we will see it in a moment
because we'll do an example. Uh but what
I meant is that so in practice after you
define the Hamiltonian uh kind of
applying these so using them to solve a
problem it means that you need to
basically solve these differential
equations. And in practice, what usually
happens is that you use the third one to
express u as a function of p and x. And
then you use these two basically, you
know, feed u in kind of substitute u in
the first two differential equations.
And then you solve these differential
equations pinpointing the constants of
integration with the boundary
conditions.
>> Yes.
>> Just trying to connect what we were
looking at before to this here. So it's
we're using like the same boundary
conditions that we just bought the
balances. It's just to equate a case of
not using these OE as well, right?
>> Uh I mean the boundary conditions look
slightly different as well.
>> So this is where I am just stating the
result. Uh I'm happy to provide kind of
the derivations of how we get there.
We'll have a sketch of a proof. So will
be some intuition there. Uh but the
point is that the derivations are not
that insightful. Um yeah the but yes the
point is that you have some boundary
conditions which are not exactly the
same as we were doing before
mechanically we use them exactly in the
same way but they just look different
>> the difference between what we were
previously doing before was a lot of
notation didn't just change um the main
difference is more instead of just
finding like a position or so which is x
of t we're now doing it as a control
system
>> yeah so I can understand the confusion
that comes with a lot of notation
changing. So the point is that up until
now we introduced calculus of variation
as a tool for solving infinite
dimensional optimization problems
detached from optimal control and so we
are using like only X or W as a
combination of everything. Now we are
basically doing kind of the you know the
hop in the direction of optimal control
and we want to use the exact same tools
for now formulating everything notation
included as an optimal control problem
where we have the dynamics f we have the
states x and we have the controls u.
Does it clarify? Uh yes and the and so
the equations though are slightly
changing. Uh go on the front like but
the equation it looks extremely similar
and that's on purpose because the only
difference is we're adding the u
>> uh if I mean what equation are you
referring to this one here? Um so yeah
that equation there essentially u just
became x dot it was previously x dot in
the previous time and now it's u because
we are now controlling that versus x
>> if if now we are controlling the system
>> through the coupling of so you were free
variables we control u's and we control
x through u
>> uh before we could control directly x
>> yes
>> um sorry I'm just confused with what's
the difference between the Hamiltonian
and the GA function that they defined
earlier.
>> Mhm. Yes. Uh so the
kind of the GA function you should see
it as uh I basically I wanted to give
you the intuition of how to handle this
sort of constraints that couples uh you
know in the optimal control notation
couples controls with states. And I did
this here. We had like a simplified
objective function, right? We only had
this G over here. And so in this
specific case, kind of augmenting, so
kind of taking these constraints into
the objective function and penalizing
for them bo down to this augmented G. In
the more general setting, which is the
one we care about, uh we formally define
this Hamiltonian, which is again
intuitively the same thing. uh but this
is the much more general uh formalism if
that makes sense.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> Yes.
>> Question. What's the difference between
the is the Hamiltonian the same as the
lrangeian we had in previous lectures
where we had to lambdas and stuff?
>> Uh you could interpret it as the inde
the analog of the lrangeian. Yeah.
>> Okay. And so in practice kind of the uh
necessary conditions
meaning the these ones here essentially
represent a system of 2n differential
equations of sec well sec um a set of
second order uh 2n first order
differential equations and m algebraic
equations which is the third
uh and in order to solve these we would
basically need to pinpoint these uh
constants of integrations. And so we'll
do this by uh using the boundary
conditions as we were doing before. But
this is just to give you a sense that at
the end of the day we will have uh two n
constants of integrations and we will
need uh 2n uh boundary conditions to
pinpoint those constants of integration
actually. So here I'm mentioning kind of
2 n + one. Can you think of the case
where we need the plus one?
So again here we're just mechanically
thinking of we'll have a set of
differential equations uh and we need
the
appropriate number of boundary
conditions to pinpoint those constants
or integrations.
and we will see it in the example but
essentially the additional one will be
to pinpoint the final time
but now I think it's it's good that we
go through an example to to see this
mechanically
Okay.
Okay. All right.
So the problem we'll be looking at is
the one where we are trying to
essentially optimize uh the equivalent
of a particle on a on a line. Right? So
we have x of t which represents uh kind
of our position of our particle at time
t. uh and this is defined by uh a system
which is a uh second order uh through
some second order dynamics uh which
essentially means that we are directly
controlling the acceleration of this
particle. So we're assuming uh unit mass
and so f equals ma we are directly
controlling the acceleration of this
particle
and specifically we want uh to steer
this system from an initial condition
whereby
uh at time zero so x of
0 is equal to 10. So we are at a
position 10 and with u uh zero velocity
because the derivative of x at time 0 is
equal to zero
and we want to reach the origin.
So we want that x of tf is equal to zero
and also we want to reach reach it with
uh zero uh velocity.
So this is uh what we want to do in this
system and specifically we want to do
this while minimizing the following uh
functional j uh which is uh comprised of
two parts. Uh we have a running cost
which is is defined as uh 1/2 uh the
integral between t0 and tf of b u uh u t
^2. Now this uh essentially represents
the analog of wanting to minimize
control effort for example
and the we have a terminal cost that is
12 * alpha ts^ 2 which represents the
essentially wanting to get to the
objective uh you know quickly
essentially we don't want to take a very
long time so we're penalizing final time
now these two terms are kind of balanced
and weighted from these two scaling
factors alpha and B. And so depending on
uh which one is bigger, we might want to
reach our objective by so if B is very
large, we want to do this by uh not
reading be really cautious with the
acceleration that we have. Uh on the
opposite, if alpha is very large, we
want to reach it very quickly
potentially uh at the expenses of a
larger control effort. Yes,
>> I just wanted so using that halfart that
just says minimize. So you don't want as
much acceleration as possible.
Yes, exactly.
>> Yeah,
>> yeah. Yeah, indeed. So, we are in the
setting where we are defining a
functional and uh in general we're
always minimizing costs in our in our
optimal control problems. Yeah. And in
this case, the final time is assumed to
be free.
>> Are these square kind of like generalize
how they do the cost or is that
>> this is just a choice. Yeah.
>> Okay. So, uh why is this interesting? I
think it is particularly interesting
because uh it it's a a simple example
that kind of encapsulates a lot of the
uh characteristics of what you would see
in kind of real world optimal control
problems. Right? So we have uh
some cost which balances control effort
and final time. We have a free final
time which we want to optimize over. Um
and in general it's a problem that if I
were to have given this to you a couple
weeks back you probably wouldn't have
known how to start with right and now we
indeed have uh general for formalism
which we could use to tackle these kind
of problems.
Okay so let's let's get started.
So in in general u
in optimal control we want to be uh
methodical. So let's apply and and
follow step by step the the recipe. So
the first thing that we want to do is
define the uh Hamiltonian right
which we defined as G plus our co-state
variables again the analog of the lang
multipliers uh uh transpose F.
Now in order to apply any of this the
first thing that we have to do is so
remember that
you might have noticed but here we're
looking at a second order uh system and
everything that we derived so far kind
of assumes we have a first order uh
system. So the first thing that we want
to do is cast this problem as a first
order differential equation which we
know how to do and specifically the way
we do this is by
constructing the analog of this system
which is essentially by adding an
additional uh dimension whereby X do one
is equal to X2
and X dot2 is equal to U
right? So we saw this I think Monday
last week
and for us this here will be F right.
Okay.
Now remember that we have one costate
variable for
every state variable. And so we define
P
of T
as the vector of P1T
and P2T. So we essentially have two
components.
Okay. But so now we have all of the
ingredients to define our Hamiltonian.
So
h will be uh g which from our actually
it's probably useful to keep the the
problem over here from our definition of
the functional
g is
12 b u ^2
again this is g
plus
the vector of co-state variables p1 1 T
p2t
transpose
x2t. So our f
uh u
right which
we can expand as 12 b
u 2 t plus p1
t x 2t
plus p 2 t
uh u t.
I hope this is uh big enough for the
ones in the back.
Yeah.
Okay.
Okay. So now that we have the
Hamiltonian,
let's be methodical and indeed define
our differential equations, our
optimality conditions. Yes.
>> Have to cast it like let's say it was
just we were only controlling the
velocity
um instead of the acceleration.
That makes sense. Um what would we have
our app? Would it just be x itself and
then would there still be the u or like
what would your app?
Um
>> now I'm not exactly sure about this
specific example but in general if you
have a system where it would be just a
first order system it will be as it is
so you would be ready to apply it
>> now
would it still be a twoimensional
>> no in that case
>> yes
okay so let us take the
and define the first of our conditions
which is that
x dot has to be equal to the derivative
of the Hamiltonian with respect to the
costate vector which is indeed uh we
know already this is our f right
which just to spell it out this
essentially means x1 dot equals uh x2
and x2 dot equals uh u. Uh so now here
I'm omitting uh t uh in between
parenthesis just to save on space but
everything here is a function of time.
Okay so this is the kind of the
intuitive one right just our dynamics.
Now for the second one, for the second
one
what we have is P dot is equal to minus
the derivative of the Hamiltonian with
respect to X
which is equal to P1 dot.
So the Hamiltonian
is this guy over here. So taking the
partial derivative with respect to X1.
So there is no x1 here. So it's just p1
dot equals z. And then
p2 dot in this case uh equals
uh
negative uh p1.
Yes. because we're taking the derivative
with respect to um
x2. Yeah.
Okay.
Does this make sense?
Yeah. Perfect. [snorts]
Now for the third uh what we do is that
we have set the derivative with respect
to the of the Hamiltonian in the u uh
which is equal to b u plus uh p2 from
here
which means that u is equal to 1 / b p2.
So this is for example to refer to your
comment before what I what I meant by in
the third case we want to express uh u
was a function of uh p and x in this
case is only p
okay and so from this if we kind of are
putting these two uh together what we
get is that
x do 2 is equal to -1 / p uh p2
Right.
Okay. So just as a caveat in general uh
this is where uh you would stop. Right.
So you derive the optimality conditions
uh you would feed this to a solver
together with the appropriate boundary
conditions and hope that the solver
converges and you're done. Now for the
purpose of uh you know being methodical
let's let's try to solve this uh
analytically.
Okay. So
we know from
um
from over there that P1
uh dot of T is equal to uh zero. So I'm
just rewriting here which essentially
means that uh P1 of T
is equal to uh C1. So now we're starting
to see our constants of integration
starting to pop up.
So we know from P2 of T that has to be
equal to negative P1
of T again from up there that this means
that uh P uh 2 dot is equal to uh
negative C1 right
[snorts]
okay which essentially means
that P2 of T is equal to C1 T plus uh
C2.
Okay. Then kind of again going forward
we know that x uh 2 dot is equal to
1 / b * p2t
again we got this from over here so I'm
just rewriting it
which is equal to 1 / b multiplied by
um
minus C1 T + C2 because this is what we
just derived
which essentially means that uh
integrating we get X of X2 of T is equal
to -1 / B * - C1 / 2 T ^ 2 + C2 T + C3
>> [snorts]
>> Okay. So here to avoid having to carry
over this uh C3 term in the following uh
computations I I'm already kind of
exploiting the fact that we know that
our initial conditions are fixed. So
specifically
we know that
um let's just write it here
x dot at time z is equal to zero. So the
we start from a zero velocity condition
which means that x 2
is equal to zero
which essentially means that kind of
combining these two kind of C3 is equal
to zero it.
[snorts]
Okay.
Uh actually let's go over here.
Now we keep going and we have that x1. T
uh is equal to x2 t.
again from leveraging our differential
equations right there
which means which is equal to -1 / b*
- c1 / 2 t ^ 2 + c2 t
where by integrating it means that x1 t
is equal to 1 - 1 / b * c1 T1 / 6 T
power 3 + CT * T 2 + C4,
[snorts]
right? Okay, so here we essentially
spelled out all of our uh differential
equations
and now what we need is we need our
boundary conditions to pinpoint all of
our constants of integrations which in
this case is C1 C2 C3 C4 C3 we already
used it here but it's it's those four
plus the final time TF. So we need to
pinpoint those five constants of
integration and so we need five uh
boundary conditions to do so.
So again what do we know? So we know
that x 1 0 is equal to to 10. We know
that x2 0 is equal to zero. So our
position at the initial time is 10 and
we are at zero velocity. [snorts]
Uh we know that x1 at the final time tf
is equal to zero and the we have to get
there uh with zero velocity and so x2 tf
is equal to zero. So here we have four
uh boundary conditions and now to get
the fifth we essentially look at our
table
and we look at the case when uh the
final position is uh specified right. So
uh this one here. So x of tf is a
specified final state. And so this means
that we need to include this additional
boundary condition over here.
So what does that boundary condition
look like in practice is that we need to
take the Hamiltonian um evaluate it at
final time. I'm using this notation to
mean evaluated at final time to avoid
writing a sequence of parenthesis. Um,
plus the derivative of the terminal cost
uh also evaluated at the final time must
be equal to zero. So this is our fifth
uh boundary condition exactly how we uh
got it from the table.
So uh let's just do that.
So the Hamiltonian evaluated at the
uh final time
is 1 / 2 B U 2
TF
plus P1
TF * X2 TF
plus P2
TF * U
TF
right so here I just took our expression
of the Hamiltonian and I just evaluate
it at the final time.
Now uh we know that this is equal to
zero
um because we know that x2
of tf is equal to zero right
from here
and we know that this part over here uh
is
b
u
right from
where is it?
Uh can you spot it?
Well uh yeah from here for example.
Yeah. So we know that P2 evaluated at TF
is equal to negative B UT.
Okay. And so kind of this essentially
means that the Hamiltonian evaluated at
the final time is equal to -1
/ 2 * B U^2
TF.
So this is the first of our two terms
that we are computing of our boundary
condition. We just need the last one
which is the derivative of the terminal
cost evaluated at the final time
which is equal to alpha tf. So again the
terminal cost for us is uh
is this one here. So 12 alpha tf squ.
Are we able to see over there? I saw you
were. Does this help?
>> Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. And so basically summing
these two uh parts together what we get
is that
1 / 2 b u^2
tf
plus alpha
uh tf must be equal to zero. Right? So
essentially we got our
five
uh boundary conditions uh
right to pinpoint our five constants of
integration. Yes.
the X1
C2.
>> Uh yes. Uh
>> or is there
>> Wait, so you're saying that this should
be one half or
>> C2 in the middle?
>> Inside the brackets C2 C2 T²
>> uh
>> on the far right.
>> Yeah, I see. Yeah, I think I think
you're right. Yeah.
It should be like this. Yeah.
Yeah, this makes sense.
Okay. And so basically what happens is
that uh
if we now we have all of the ingredients
uh and to pinpoint our constants of
integration and what we get is that the
solution actually looks like uh
something like this. So we can pinpoint
all our constants of integration and
specifically we have that the final
times look like 1800 * b you know
divided by alpha^ 1/5. Now uh well this
looks like you know an okay beast uh it
kind of aligns with intuition right
because so the higher b so the higher
our uh weight on the control effort the
the the
higher the final time so we'll tend to
go slower. On the other hand, the higher
alpha, so the h the the lower will be
the final time. So the more we'll be
quicker at at reaching our our
[clears throat] final condition.
>> Yes.
>> For this if um initial condition by the
table, is there any sort of like
intuition behind it or should we just
like take it out and just memorize it
and not worry about it?
>> Yeah. So the this is a great question
because it's a great segue into kind of
the next uh slide which is indeed uh
trying to give you some intuition to
into how those uh equations come up. Um
well in in to be exact the boundary
conditions they're just um
let's go through this and then maybe we
can uh we can take this question again.
So specifically okay so we introduced
the optimality conditions we showed how
to use them. Now I want to just spend a
couple of minutes to giving you an
intuition into how those are derived.
Yes.
>> Yeah. So solve for the final option by
time. Is there a way to solve for
control time or no?
>> Uh that experiment you have but you
never solve for
>> no well of course you would get also the
once you have everything here from the
your solver you would get also kind of
all the triplet you would get x u and uh
p. Yeah.
Okay. And so specifically
so remember how we uh derived the uh
uler equation in the unconstrained case
and specifically our argument there is
that we started from the variation. So
we took the uh fundamental theorem of
calculus of variation. So
uh that the variation has to be equal to
zero. Right? And so specifically we got
to here by so we turned this into an
actionable uh condition by starting from
the increment uh taking the linear part
of that increment which equal to the uh
variation and then we derived that
condition on the integrant of that
linear part uh by leveraging the fact
that we could have um any potential
admissible variation uh delta x. So this
is just that I ahead of what we did on
on Monday. Uh so ideally to derive those
conditions we do a very similar process.
However, now uh the problem here is that
those variations cannot be arbitrary
because these are coupled together
through the dynamics. So the u's and the
x's cannot really vary or arbitrary.
And so the way we kind of we can derive
this is that we
um first of all uh to here we consider a
simplified setting where we set to zero
the terminal penalty and we uh assume
that the final time and the x of df are
fixed and given.
And in order to derive the optimality
conditions for uh for this case, we
consider the augmented uh cost function
which is exactly how we did uh which is
basically what we did before um which is
essentially a trick to u
basically add zero to our original cost
g. The way the the reason I'm saying
that this is uh a trick is because if
you look at this term over here we have
s f minus x dot and since this is an
optimality condition in order to be
optimal the point also has to be
feasible and so this has to be equal to
zero right so essentially this is a
trick where we are defining these
augmented cost by nominally adding zero
but we are introducing these costate
variables or the analog of the langen
which we will see later. We can then
kind of use these in order to select
those cost state variables in such a way
to simplify our analysis.
>> Yes.
>> Sorry. Um on the previous how did it go
from not knowing you because that's what
we were solving for getting like of that
final circle problem to getting that t
is the one.
>> Yes. Do you do you mind if we take this
in a couple of minutes? I just want to
go through this slide. Yeah. Thanks. Um
so essentially we are in a situation
where the augmented cost function is
something that you that takes this uh
augmented g that we just did and so by
doing an exact like exactly the same
process as we did to derive the uler
equation we essentially rewrite the
fundamental theorem of calculus of
variation in this you know nasty looking
beast. But if you think about it, this
is exactly the same thing we were doing
in the Uler equation where uh we had our
partial derivatives of the cost uh which
we obtained by basically doing a tailor
expansion of our uh increment. Um this
term here corresponds to the term where
we were using the integration by part to
eliminate the dependency on delta x dot.
And just to make sure that this is
slightly more explicit. So this term
over here, so the derivative of GA with
respect to the costate is just the term
of our dynamics which we're looking at
before. Uh this is equal to negative
costate and this is equal to these two
uh partial derivatives. Now the argument
here is that as we did before we want to
get an an actionable condition by
leveraging the fact that the variations
could be arbitrary such that everything
inside the integrant has to be equal to
zero in order for the entire integral to
be equal to zero. The problem here is
that out of these
all of these terms the only kind of
freely v uh kind of variations that we
could freely vary are the ones in u
because everything else is kind of
coupled with respect to u. So what we
want to do is that we ideally want to
remove all of this extra stuff be left
only with this part here and here we can
actually do the argument that we want to
do. So the uh first one is kind of
trivially uh satisfied because for a
point to be optimal it has to be
feasible. So this part here is actually
zero. So this term cancels out. Now for
these two terms remember that we
introduced kind of the cost states kind
of arbitrarily right so we fictitiously
augmented our cost function adding zero
with these additional costate functions.
So here we actually could choose the
cost state in a quote unquote smart way
in order to cancel everything out. And
so exactly this is exactly what we do.
So we set the PS to be equal to this
other stuff. And so we are left with
only this term where the variations are
arbitrary. And here we could do the
argument uh that this thing has to be
equal to zero. And so if you kind of
think back at what the actual necessary
optimity conditions were, these were
exactly those conditions. So remember we
had three kind of two differential
equations and some algebraic equations.
The first one was that the dynamics need
to be satisfied and it's this term over
here. The second one was a condition on
the co-state variables and it's this
term over here. And then the last one
was that this term over here needs to be
equal to zero. So I invite you to kind
of do the mapping between these slides
and the actual formulation where the
only difference is that we're being more
elegant by defining the Hamiltonian.
And this is all for today. Thanks.